big ben is back he's gotten a haircut
chris he's gotten a haircut and he's
gotten a shave he was looking like a
rugged
mountain man yukon cornelius not that
long ago and this is very recent he was
throwing with his guys and then he
decided after the throwing session
because he said he's not going to shave
until he throws a legit nfl pass he
believes it was a legit nfl pass that
was thrown to the likes of juju smith
schuster and james connor so big ben is
now clean shaven with short hair the
elbow is healed he believes and he's
ready to go for 2020. that's one of the
stories that's been overlooked
throughout the pandemic and the run-up
to the draft and free agency and there's
just this vague sense that ben
rothersburg is in the early days of
breaking down as he gets closer to 40
jake laser stepped into a hornet's nest
a few weeks ago suggesting that the ben
roethlisberger offseason workout plan is
a far cry from tom brady's i mean look
it's the truth has anyone ever accused
ben roth of eating avocado ice cream so
uh i i think it makes sense to see what
kind of shape he's in
is the elbow healed and was last year
chris just the first step in what could
be
a gradual breakdown of the body of a guy
who really hasn't taken the kind of care
of his body that a bit of tom brady or
other high-end quarterbacks have
yeah i think that's you know a
legitimate question by us jay glazier
anybody i mean hey we respect big ben i
know you think he's underrated i do too
i mean he's a hell of a football player
we know that he's a huge difference
maker for the pittsburgh steelers but
mike i mean you're saying it this is not
a guide that i think is going to go down
in the record books for like you know
off season workout regimens or you know
off season workout diet plans you can
see that i mean it doesn't take a fool
or a dummy to look at ben roethlisberger
and go well his body doesn't look
exactly like tom brady's or drew brees
no you know i think they have a
different approach to their off season
you know i found out from big ben a
little last year it sounds like in the
off season he kind of lets his body rest
he's just a dad he you know stays in
somewhat shape but it's not going to
like dictate his day on a daily basis
he's not going to throw a ton of
footballs
but either way
you know if the elbow is healed i know
big ben can throw the football i know
that but i think the body is a big
question i do you know and again unlike
brady and breeze too where we got to
give big ben a lot of credit he took a
beating for about a seven or eight year
period of his career and you know i
think we all have kind of forgotten that
here sitting in 2020 right now but mike
i know you you lived there close to
pittsburgh and those late you know 2009
2010 11 12 i mean he took a beating as a
quarterback and you know played through
injuries and i think all of that is kind
of catching up to him a little bit right
now but i would think he's got a year or
two of good play left in him at least
i don't think people give him enough
credit for the beating he took because
he's had that reputation
of a guy who embellishes his injuries
and exaggerates his injuries right
there's always been that little hint
that little extra where you know ooh my
arm it's broken
but maybe it is broken i you know i mean
and and that's the thing even if there's
any little extra that he adds to it for
sympathy or
for pride or honor or look at what i'm
trying to gut out or maybe you'll
appreciate me more if i can't play for
the key drive of a key regular season
game whatever the case may be it doesn't
change the fact that he has had the crap
beat out of him over the past 15 years
and he is a throwback in a lot of ways i
mean you've got these quarterbacks who
are like dolph lundgren in rocky
iv without the steroids but you know
like basically created in a laboratory
and everything is measured out to the
droplet of
hydration and and nutrition and and
exercise and rothersburg is just showing
up and saying oh here i am it's football
season give me the ball let's go play
and and there's a charm to that i think
we should embrace that we should i don't
know why we i i look and and i know he's
had off-field issues that make him less
sympathetic but i don't know why
we don't appreciate more the fact that
this guy
is different
from all of the other older quarterbacks
out there in that he really is like a
quarterback out of the 70s or the 80s
who's just gonna who's going to say in
the offseason i'll i'll be ready for
football when football comes and really
doesn't spend all the time getting ready
and then when he's
when he's ready to go he's ready to go
and he does what he has to do to get
ready for week one well you know i think
you hit on a lot of things that kind of
like cloud his image a little bit you
know one uh you're right he's got here
the old school style of play of football
and yeah he looks like a guy that was
like you know oh i'm gonna go out here
and throw some footballs and i'm gonna
drink a beer and then i'm gonna go eat
one of those raffle burger sandwiches
when it's over and just enjoyed the
night you know he does look like one of
those guys and you know to mike to what
you're saying a little bit of a diva
there's no doubt you're right he likes
to let everybody know when something's
banged up and he's not afraid to you
know show the cameras hey i got an issue
here and i think he lets it known in the
locker room and things like that but you
got to respect the play there's no doubt
like you said this guy that's been to
three super bowls he won two of them i
know he won one of them it wasn't like
glorious stats or anything like that but
either way he had years of carrying a
a pittsburgh steelers football team that
was really poor on the offensive line
had no running game and he played with
the throwback style of play where you
know it was in the pocket it was kind of
backyard football within the pocket and
he'd have people all over them and i hey
listen i'll never forget the year they
went to the super bowl and rex ryan with
the jets who had just upset the new
england patriots and tom brady said you
know we had a we were okay with them but
man big ben he gave us more problems
than anybody because of his ability to
stay in the pocket and scramble and do
things off schedule so yeah we can't
forget the greatness of what is big ben
and let it be clouded by some of the off
the field or other stuff that's gone on
yeah that was 10 years ago the steelers
last super bowl appearance the patriots
have had something to do with the
steelers not being back over the course
of the last decade the steelers continue
to be a very competitive team and
heading into 2020
and this is one of my observations it's
a narrative that is held up year after
year i've lived most of my life in and
around pittsburgh
and
when the expectations are high for the
steelers
really ever since the the end of their
their super bowl runs in the 70s where
they won four championships in six years
in the 80s the 90s last decade and now
when the expectation's high they fail to
meet it when the expectations are low or
just like really vague or like uh it's
just that's when they end up having a
great year and i think this year the
expectations are in that kind of like
[Music]
i
i don't know what to expect i don't know
what they're going to be they were bad
last year in large part because they
didn't have ben roethlisberger for 14
games but with no le'veon bell with no
antonio brown with the ravens looking as
good as they are with the browns
possibly
maybe finally getting it right with the
bengals now having the promise of a joe
burrow where do the steelers really fit
into this chris and i think that this
plays right into their hands because
they they still have plenty of talent on
both sides of the ball the defense has
sneakily and quietly gotten better and
better and better it was the weakness of
that team for a long time i remember
talking to ike taylor about that where
you know it's it's a far cry from the
90s where it was all defense and no
offense now it's all offense and no
defense well you know the defense has
gotten better and now the question is
can the offense hold up its end of the
bargain what do you think
yeah i mean that's that is the question
of the football team there's no you know
the defense
you know to what you're saying is
special i mean it is to play the way
they played towards the second half of
the year last year or really the whole
year and know that hey each week we got
to go out there in defense we got to win
the football game and we got to keep
teams you know somewhere around 20 or
below for our offense that had no
identity last year to win so i look at
the defense as being nfl elite special
you know the scheme the front seven
special they did lose javon hargrave
that's things the secondaries got better
the offense is interesting
there's questions there's potential
there's a little bit of everything there
we got questions about yeah big ben
roethlisberger you know is juju smith
schuster as good as we really thought he
was without antonio brown can some of
these young receivers you know like
james washington and deontay johnson and
chase clayton will truly contribute to
the football team this year do they have
a difference maker at running back i
really like the kid they dropped it out
of maryland anthony mcfarland he's kind
of like a philip lindsay type out of
denver so it's similar there but as you
know yeah there's a lot of good things
we say there but you got to go out and
do it so the potential is there but it's
kind of a young unproven group and now
you got the one proven guy of the
football team or the offense i should
say with big ben
and now he's got to prove it to us that
his arm is healthy and he's healthy and
he's still capable of playing at a high
level so you know that's where i think
it stands right now some some some
questions to answer on that offensive
side of the ball in pittsburgh
yeah running back a work in progress in
large part because of injury james
connor followed a promising 2018 with an
injury riddle 2019. the receiver
position they need to really get these
guys to step up the recent draft picks
you just miss schuster not the same
without antonio brown there to attract
extra attention i mean smith schuster
had a phenomenal year in 2018 he was the
team mvp it was one of the reasons it
all came to a head week 17 when antonio
brown left the team because it had been
disclosed within the organization that
juju smith schuster was the team mvp
antonio brown was resentful of that and
took off and that was that and last year
without antonio juju not nearly the same
guy and we'll see whether or not all
these other guys can come in and get it
done what about the offensive line one
of your big concerns was when mike
munchek left for the denver broncos the
offensive line was going to go the other
way and they won their super bowls
last decade with historically bad
offensive lines where does that line
stand right now in your estimation
yeah well you know to your point with
the last decade thing that's why i think
big ben deserves a little more credit
than people give him sometimes because
you're right the offensive lines weren't
special he had to make a lot of a lot
happen himself in the passing game you
know the offensive line still a really
good pass-blocking offensive line you
know yeah they lost ramon foster they
got guys there to replace him and then
wisniewski there they signed him in free
agency he'll be able to do it tackle
play still really good but they're
coming to
the end of the shelf life for this
offensive line to where they're going to
have to start thinking about retooling
it rebuilding it everybody getting up
there in age a little bit you know
pouncey at center hey he's coming to the
end here i mean not to say he's done but
he's he's at the end of the prime of his
career so i you know again i think a big
part that's missed from their football
team last year especially without
muntjac is you know the physical running
game le'veon bell not being there james
connor not being healthy that was
certainly an issue but also to that
point with the running game last year or
a juju smith schuster it's really hard
to be successful when your quarterback
is below average and nobody scares your
pass game and i think that was a big
issue too so i still think the offensive
line is good i don't think it's great
anymore you know two three years ago
mike i would have gone oh this
pittsburgh line's one of the three four
best offensive lines in football now you
know somewhere outside the top ten right
around the top ten right around that
area but still good enough to win
football games certainly
yeah and marquis pouncey has been that
cornerstone in the center of the
offensive line a a chain that really
goes back decades for the steelers
whether it was jeff harding's germany
dawson hall of famer uh mike webster
hall of famer i remember ray mansfield
was the center of the steelers and he
was an anchor there when i first became
aware of football uh one last important
point before we take our first break of
the morning ben roethlisberger has a
reputation on social media for blocking
everyone
everyone from his twitter account i'm
it's amazing how many people will pull
up the big ben 7 and it's got an
underscore right before it and anyone
out there now
go ahead and and do it and see you you
may be surprised by what you find
twitter.com slash underscore big ben 7
now he blames it all because it's an
official verified account it's his
account it's him
he says there's someone that he has that
runs it and i think this person spends
all day and all night just going through
the entire universe of twitter accounts
and arbitrarily blocking people because
there are some people like me who
deserve it who've been blocked and there
are others who like i don't even know
who he is
and they've been blocked it is one of
the strangest phenomena of all of social
media the countless accounts that have
been blocked by big ben 7 chris sources
tell me that you have not yet been
blocked my goal through this segment is
to get you blocked so
k lady who is responsible for big ben's
twitter account please block c sims qb 2
m's qb
she won't do that big ben won't do that
he knows i might say a little something
here and there i keep it real but big
ben knows that i think he's one of the
most underrated quarterbacks in the
history of the sport he's a legend he is
he's a first half first dollar hall of
famer in my in my mind i think so too
i know i think so too
well yeah but you're just more of a jerk
than me so i understand them blocking
you that over me i get that
you're a suck-up you're more of a
suck-up yeah that's your truth teacher's
pet here's an apple big ben i like you
so much
uh he didn't eat apples
with a gallon of ice cream and a keg of
beer
unblock me
all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports